una campaña de verano comienza la pelea
por el Palacio de la moncloa los
españoles se preparan para las urnas en
una campaña atípica en plena temporada
estival pero de vacaciones no hay nada
especialmente para el presidente del
gobierno Pedro Sánchez quien Busca la
reelección el líder del partido
socialista convocó estos comicios de
manera anticipada después de que la
derecha y la Ultra derecha arrasaron en
las elecciones regionales y locales
ganando la mayoría de las comunidades
autónomas y las ciudades más importantes
España es mucho mejor que el partido
popular y que vos y por eso les vamos a
ganar el próximo 23 de Julio el partido
popular y vox los dos principales
partidos de derecha y extrema derecha
han reforzado sus lazos compactos de
gobierno a nivel regional el PP lidera
los sondeos Pero la pregunta es si su
electorado lo castigará por su
acercamiento con una formación que
cuestiona la violencia de género la
causa feminista y estigmatiza a la
población migrante vamos a ganar las
elecciones entre todos y este es el
momento la democracia
es el momento del cambio las encuestas
señalan que ningún partido llegará en
solitario a los 176 escaños que dan
mayoría absoluta en el congreso de los
diputados el PP se apoyaría en Box
mientras que los socialistas podrían
contar con la plataforma sumar de la
vicepresidenta Segunda del gobierno
Yolanda Díaz